what
initially sparked you to this character
in this script
uh a couple three things um
the opportunity to work with edward
james almost
and the the story
i like telling these stories like being
part of telling these stories
[Music]
and i figured well there's something i
can learn about the
the the almond uh growing industry um
although that was obviously going to
come with the come with the territory
but uh
yeah and also not only to work with
eddie but um a whole cast of
really great characters uh
martin sheen and kate bosworth and holly
joel
and you know although i i didn't get a
chance to really work with um
alfred molina and but uh everybody else
like pablo
sharbra it was just a it looked like it
was a stellar cast
um that was going to be uh a lot of fun
yeah it's a murderer's row um
speaking of learning about almond
farming what was some of your
research in that world like what did you
find out about that world
um how important the uh
the central valley almond industry is to
the rest of the world
the amount of almonds that are exported
from
california uh is
uh was quite surprising to me um and
and therefore how uh
how um uh
uh shocking it was that this uh
oil company um
[Music]
was doing what it what it was doing um
and getting away with it and that it
took
one farmer to you know blow the whistle
on them
it's a sort of a clash of
two titans although oil companies
obviously
you know a behemoth compared to
an almond farmer but
he i i learned a lot that that was very
uh
that was very enlightening to me yeah um
so edward james almost he both directs
the film and he's uh one of the stars
what is he like as a director versus an
actor are there like
key differences or does it feel sort of
similar or what is what is the
difference
there uh he juggled those two things
seamlessly
um as an actor he's so
grounded uh i
really have sincerely admired his
ability to
hold the camera um and
with a very uh
economy of of
movement of actorly things very
economical
um always comes across as a very uh
deep well-rounded character
um and you can also sense that
whatever what a good person he is um
and that's what was a delight every day
he's fun
he knows what it what it takes to make a
movie
uh the work is hard um but he was
more than well prepared each day to
shoot what we needed to shoot
and uh you realize you know in the end
this
has got to be a good time we're going to
do good work but
you know he was an actor's director
and a director's actor that you know
couldn't ask for a better one best in
both worlds
um there's this fight scene that the two
of you have
that uh well a fight scene maybe in
quotes it kind of devolves into like
a silly sort of laughter filled
wrestling match what was the process of
staging that scene executing that scene
were there ever any versions where like
it was a little more intense
what was that yeah it was say okay let's
go for this we're sitting on a couch
and okay you're gonna get up here and
then i'm gonna push you and then i'm
gonna tackle you and get on the ground
and let's just do it and it was
it was hilarious we were laughing
sincerely laughing our asses off because
this uh
but you know in retrospect i think
it was important to establish the bond
between these two guys
you know the friendship the trust and
also the boundaries
um and uh eddie just said i think we got
to go for it
and and we did and i it stuck out in my
mind as being one of the more
uh enjoyable days um
and also a really significant moment in
the journey of both
characters um had you not had that scene
i think you'd still have the
relationship but that
at the get-go laid the groundwork for um
for the depth of the relationship yeah
um
what do you think is going on deep
within
fred your character what is sort of the
the central
emotion or drive that kind of uh
uh decides his decisions his emotions
a couple of things uh they touch on the
fact that his wife
has died he's by himself you know he's
he's hoping to get out of the game he
has his dream of a sailboat
and maybe retiring from you know the
arduous work of
of maintaining that his um his his
business concerns
the almonds and uh
so there's that bubbling is he
going to actually enter in
engage in this battle given
all of that um how much does he care
uh his love of his almonds
and uh and then when he's
awakened to the
to what shore oil is doing i i think
that
triggered a um
a defense of of the land a defense
of uh not only his business
but uh this is wrong they're poisoning
the earth
um i am or as fred the farmer i am
providing
food for the world they're poisoning my
food
and so on a very you know
very basic level uh
i think that got to him and said yes
these people deserve and when he learned
about how much money they're
stealing from him well just on a you
know business sense that that was uh you
know that
that certainly made him get fired up
um speaking of poisoning the water maybe
this is an odd question
there's that scene where your
character's taking a shower and he kind
of realizes
he even tastes the water and says oh
it's the water
as an actor when you are playing a scene
where you realize water is unhealthy and
water
is coming down on you is there a part of
your brain that starts to think
is this water literally coming down on
me safe
does that sort of like start to collide
or anything like that
uh yeah i think that was the intention
of the scene
is a kind of a wake-up call to what we
take for granted
that the water coming out of our faucets
is uh
is good for us and clean and healthy and
pure
and etc etc you know think of flint
michigan
you know think of erin brockovich think
of
you know what the groundwater
may be affected by the fires in northern
california
anywhere there has been well across the
midwest with the um
roundup and all of the poisons that
putting into the soil
and here coming out of a shower head is
potentially
a a toxic source which we
consider or well reconsider which is
vital to
survival on the planet so that's the
intention of the scene it's brief it's a
brief moment
but you picked it off that's what eddie
was hoping to achieve in that moment
yeah um there's a
not soon after that scene there's a
pretty wild scene where you
are cladding just a towel and a golf
club
and you go and smash the heck out of a
window of a hummer and it looks like
it's in one take
yeah how was that yeah did you actually
like smash
a window out of a hummer yeah yeah we we
kind of went through the
the steps you know the process but said
well we
we we got to go we did try a couple of
takes but i realized
oh i'm not going to be able to hit it we
better i'm not going to break the window
you know okay stop we'll do it again but
um
yeah that was uh that was a tricky
little
thing to to accomplish um but
i i think it's one of those scenes in
the film a lot like the wrestling scene
where
this is hilarious this looks like you
know some kind of
cartoon weird satire comedy
you know mad comedy but the um the
intensity
the the motivation for that i think
is part and parcel of the whole
litigation um this is he finally
realizes that he's been
has been taken he's sort of been
betrayed he's been duped scammed
and that kind of passion
was i think was necessary to see
in the character which would propel him
forward into taking the case
yeah that makes a lot of sense uh i
think i have time for one more question
uh we'll do a silly one for you in this
film
i think we have three very
exquisite pieces of facial hair there's
your beard there's edward james almost
this beard and then there's haley joel
osment's beard
uh if you had to rank those beards
best of worst what do we got what's your
power ranking
uh well obviously haley's was younger
and fresher and fuller
um but i'd take eddie's
this is number one yeah i take care of
his number one
and then you've got to be number two
come on well
uh it was a little scant and you know a
little
it was more like the almond grove after
poison for a while
awesome i think that's all the time i
have thanks david all right
thanks greg